Breaking Bad Breaking la planète  breaking probably a huge fan okay is  there anything to replace it for you  have you found anything you look better  call Saul is a good program but Breaking  Bad I think will go down I mean in terms  of both the writing of it  I wonder how in the world can you end  this thing you know right they ended it  right the talent that was on there I  mean that you know there were there were  half a dozen really outstanding actors  and actresses I mean it was I don't  think I don't think the world's gonna  see anything better than that  Vince Gilligan has he's got four stars  in might well quite a phenomenon yeah  not a broadcast yeah